we're at a historic tipping point for
women
in october 2017 the hashtag
metoo spread across the globe
[Music]
what began as a hollywood sexual assault
scandal
sparked a public reckoning around the
world
thousands of women are using two words
on social media to identify themselves
as survivors of sexual harassment and
assault
a watershed moment new laws have been
passed
and powerful men have been forced to
step down for the damage that oxfam has
done
face arrest and conviction
but now metoo is igniting wider debates
on the horizon about the ability of
legal systems to deliver justice the
problem here is our systems are not
strong enough to back them
about how men should behave around women
we don't know what the rules are and it
turns out that there's
way more of them than you thought and
about the battle for gender equality
first you had me too and now you have
now what
[Music]
[Applause]
pretoria south africa inspired by the
global metoo movement
these women are protesting about the
country's high rates of rape and
femicide
the deliberate murder of women
in south africa the number of women
killed by a partner or family member
is five times higher than the global
average
i would like to officially welcome each
and every woman here
avella fey is one of the organizers
like many of the protesters avella has
been personally affected by femicide
at the age of 13 i lost my mother to
family
she was brutally murdered in her own
home and the perpetrators
are free they're roaming the streets so
not only was i failed by someone we knew
as a family but we were failed by the
justice system
here even a recent president jacob zuma
has been accused of rape
the charges were dropped in court in
2006
but sexual and physical violence have
continued to afflict
all levels of society
[Music]
today the protesters are marching on the
parliament and have demanded a hearing
with the current president
cyril ramaphosa
[Applause]
it's soon clear the president will not
be meeting
numerous them to the office of the
president requesting their presence
today
they decide to slaughter right so if
they
decide to snap us we will show them hell
the president's no-show is little
surprise
in this country the police reported a
7.4 percent increase in all crimes
against women in the last year alone
but for the protesters today has still
been an important step in raising public
awareness
because of the society that we live in
it takes courage
for a woman to stand up and say hey
enough is not we all deserve another
[Music]
in johannesburg jiji white runs the
charity
get up women she helps victims of sexual
violence
whose cases have been dropped by the
police we're often going to meet
two ladies who have allegedly been
raped by their boss nearly half of all
rape cases reported to south african
police
do not result in an arrest
okay so before we start these two women
allege their boss sexually assaulted
them at work
we have got everybody and everything
it's going to take
to keep you guys safe gigi has come with
her colleagues
shawn and dave to take statements from
them so he just wants to ask a couple of
questions we have to do this properly
sean's role is to pass evidence to the
police and pressure them to investigate
the case properly
[Music]
foreign
come here
dude you're going to [ __ ] this okay
you're gonna help this out okay
uh did you give the statement did you go
to the cops
yeah okay and where did the case go from
there
the women suspect their boss bribed the
police to drop the investigation
he doesn't know enough people trust me
you're gonna need to know a lot more
after this one
it's time to face justice and we will go
through the whole entire thing with you
every case
every court appearance we will be there
you will not do this alone
[Music]
i think this is this is going to be a
lot uglier
and a lot bigger than what we first
thought as a third woman has now said
she was assaulted by the same boss
gigi hopes the police can be pushed to
reopen this case
but things could hit a familiar brick
wall
one of the biggest issues that we have
with the cops everybody's prepared to
take a breath
the number of women asking gigi for help
has increased since me too
yet she's worried there will be no
lasting impact in south africa
unless there are more prosecutions we
have this huge big movement that started
women are getting up they're telling
people exactly what happened and how it
happened
and the problem here is our systems are
not strong enough to back them
if we don't start getting the
prosecution done and
getting news from injustice we're just
going to end up
sliding backwards
[Music]
in america the metoo movement is
starting to have an impact on the
justice system new
day is on the horizon
following the harvey weinstein scandal
over 300 public figures have donated
millions of dollars to the time's up
legal defense fund
women have united to claim that time is
up
at these small unassuming headquarters
in washington dc
giant steps are being taken we've got
farm workers
retail hotel workers poultry nail salons
post poultry workers american women can
apply to the fund for free legal support
if they have been sexually harassed or
assaulted at work
so far there have been over 3500
applications
mainly from women in low-wage industries
it's up to interns like noah to feel the
rising number of calls
these are the list of intakes that we're
going to be sending attorneys to
we have it listed as you know workplace
sexual harassment other workplace
sex discrimination there's probably at
least 30 or 40 here just for today
some of the claims stretch back decades
the most memorable case
i had to deal with was a woman in the
military
she was sexually harassed by her
superiors by the people around her
and it kind of destroyed her life
she told me you're the first person i've
ever told this to
applications vetted here in washington
dc are passed to a network of 700
lawyers working across
48 states the fund has already filed
claims against mcdonald's
the u.s postal service and walmart
they hope this will prompt other major
organizations to change their own rules
about sexual harassment
employers have an opportunity to lead
right now they don't actually need to
wait for new laws to pass
they can right now today decide that
they're going to put this issue at the
center of their organization
metoo has prompted some companies in the
west
to introduce new measures to deal with
sexual harassment
but it has also provoked an all too
predictable backlash
i've seen signs of a kind of panic
around sexuality
and particularly a tendency to vilify
all men
people are not actually going through
any court process we are
risking a kind of sort of social media
lynching
some of the backlash is being fueled by
the anxieties of men forced to think
about their behavior
in ways they've never had to before well
everyone always feels uncomfortable and
they don't know what the rules
are and now we don't know what the rules
are and it turns out that there's way
more of them than you thought
and that the punishment for
transgressing against them is way higher
than you
could have imagined you'll say well
clinical psychologist jordan peterson is
known for his controversial and
extremely divisive views on gender
reasons how do you agree that it's
unfair if you're a woman not necessarily
and on average
he's one of the most vocal critics of me
too and its impact
the whole purpose in some sense of the
metoo movement
is to make men much more nervous about
any manifestation of any behavior that's
vaguely sexual under any circumstances
whatsoever
that are professional it's starting to
bend and distort
company policy nbc prohibits hugging
and netflix doesn't allow you to look at
anyone for more than five seconds
now really that's supposed to be a
solution who thought that through
it's the suspicion of men i would think
as men
per se that's clearly
not in anyone's interest at all
so i don't want to shock anyone i really
don't but
the world is still run by men
and i'm just not sure it's going that
well facebook co
sheryl sandberg is a leading supporter
of me too
even she is worried that some of the
reverberations could prove
counterproductive
i think me too is an opportunity it's an
opportunity to get rid of behavior that
never should have happened in the first
place
but we want to make sure this doesn't
have negative consequences
sandberg is a prominent advocate for
gender equality in business
and the founder of the women's
empowerment foundation lean in
in early 2018 a survey conducted by lean
in
found that metoo has had an adverse
effect on gender relations
us senior managers who are male are 3.5
times more likely to hesitate to have a
dinner
with a female junior colleague and
almost half of male managers
are nervous about having a one-on-one
meeting with a junior woman you can't do
work if you can't have a one-on-one
meeting
my view is everyone should be able to
work together have one-on-one meetings
and behave appropriately
but at a very minimum make access equal
if you don't feel comfortable having
dinner with women don't have dinner with
men
[Music]
in new york one pioneering company has
come up with an innovative solution to
improve relations between
sectors in the workplace there we go
that one is all set up morgan mercer is
the founder of vantagepoint
her company is exploiting the power of
virtual reality
to train men to see the world through
women's eyes
research shows that most men don't
actually have a mental framework to
reference
so most men quite literally do not
understand what sexual harassment
feels like today a team from customer
analytics
firm castora will be exposed to sexual
harassment scenarios
based on real life case studies
great great great this is going to be a
great year
rachel really important note remember
it's a party so pack something
fitting
a lot of times with sexual harassment
it's the build up
you know the body language and the
feeling of the elephant in the room
i just i honestly don't know if i want
to go anymore
what do you mean we've been working on
this for months and what about all the
after parties well honestly look that's
part of it
james was texting me all night asking me
what i'm gonna wear
so what did you guys think of it i was
like
shocked at how real it actually felt
like
yeah look at you and it's just like the
whole like how
quickly of a seemingly non-harmful
conversation about like
going out as a team or something or like
having fun as a team can turn into like
awkwardness and harassment i think it
feels like you could be here
a man was sitting too close to a woman
and i
it was right next to me right so i felt
pretty uncomfortable
and also her reactions to some of the
comments too you could pick up on some
of those cues
so the discussions that have taken place
in this
past year especially i think people are
innovating in ways to facilitate
better conversations like using
technology
stuff like this is incredibly important
right now
large companies including google and
pricewaterhousecoopers
have expressed interest in using this vr
technology to train their workforces
as has the us congress it all
points to an important shift i think
that we're at a pivotal point in society
where women's roles
are being questioned we have fought
for rights and now we're fighting for
equality in the workplace
the fallout from me too has prompted
some men in western countries
to question traditional notions of
masculinity and what it means to be a
man in society today
in britain former filmmaker david fuller
recently founded an alternative men's
collective
focused on challenging conventional
forms of male behavior
it's been coming um could you come in a
little bit let's um let's make it a
little bit more cozy
men are being challenged culturally
right now and i think the right response
to that is to up
our game at an arts festival in southern
england
david is running a workshop promoting
what he sees as the solution to the
issues raised by me too
gender is a really hot topic right now
and a lot of the things that we're
seeing out there and a lot of the anger
that
that is being felt um i think is towards
men who are not really showing up
for me the solution to the times is not
to to sort of shame masculinity
it's to really re-find healthy
masculinity and david believes the key
to this
is teaching men to be more open and
communicative about their feelings
this whole process that we're going
through it's about how we hold ourselves
back
the argument goes if more men improve
their emotional intelligence
relations with women will improve and
this will result in greater harmony
between the sexes
i always compare myself to
my my peers my friends you know i want
to be responsible but of course what
that means is you
sacrifice a lot of things in the present
because you're always trying to make
sure the future is going to be okay
i'm always amazed at how quickly men
open up
in our workshops and society was
supposed to be a bit sort of
tougher and that kind of stuff so to
kind of be able to let that go and just
be able to be ourselves felt in a safe
environment to be however you wanted to
be and not you being judged
[Applause]
it could be some time before fringe
groups like this
make any real noise in mainstream
society
but gender roles and gender relations
are being questioned more than ever
before in the wake of me too
me too started as a conversation about
sexual harassment in the workplace
but really it sheds light on that
problem and a
underlying fundamental problem the lack
of power
that women have historically had
this global movement has helped expose a
flaw at the heart of
all societies and unleash powerful
forces for change
that might just kick-start efforts to
fix it
you